[Music]
good evening to all good evening to all thank
you very much we are very happy and proud
to have been selected to be part
of this collective so I am felix
kudelka for my data model this data
model mast this we are in sophia  antipolis
today we are 35 we were created in
2018 and we have developed our
own artificial intelligence technology
a mathematical engine
called sgp isotropic genetic
programming and which has several
specificities the first the main one
is that we  has models and we have a
technology that will work very well
with small data sets so
we are very used to hearing
about dia and big data the Anglo-Saxons
are very advanced on this subject there  and
we hope that with there is and small data
is still a place to take and that we
will take it in a way also in
European terms we are obviously very attached
there is no sovereign so
these models that work  on
small  data at least that there is a
sufficient number of variables allow to
generate models which will be
extremely light and as such which will
be able to be embedded on any type of
sensor or embedded systems we
have models which can be less than
10  that we work in particular with
August at ease on nano satellites and
which have been mentioned here on an
underwater system for detecting the
qualification of the underwater threat
so there in terms of frugality we are
still between the satellite and  and the
submarine we like we have a good delta
and we have a second specificity of our
technology is that we have algae
that will be interpretable and
transparent, that means that we are
able to provide the mathematical model
that  was used for the generated so there we are
really that's what we want to bring to the
collective confidence for nothing it's this
tree to be disintegrated interprets empowered
rather than dia models that can
be used 1 we hope  re that they
will be used within the consortium
by our start-up comrades speaks through the
industrial fabric and and here I
think I said the main thing so
your willingness to exchange we are
very excited afterwards thank you all
and see you soon then
[Applause]
[Music]